واحدة من أكبر الطائرات بدون طيار في
الجيش الصيني في مهمة محفوفة بالمخاطر
لتطويق تايوان، حلقت الطائرة بدون طيار
حول الجزيرة بأكملها يوم الجمعة في
مسار طيران استفزازي للغاية تم الإعلان عنه
لأول مرة من قبل وزارة الدفاع في الجزيرة
وهو عمل وقح في نفس اليوم الذي قامت فيه
الولايات المتحدة بـ  عبرت 8 طائرات مراقبة
مضيق تايوان،
أرسلت الصين طائرات مقاتلة ووصفت الرحلة بأنها
استفزازية، وجاءت رحلة الطائرة بدون طيار أيضًا
بينما كان مستشار الأمن القومي السابق جون
بولتون في تايبيه للتعبير عن دعمه
لاستقلال تايوان، ولا نعرف ما إذا
كانت رحلة الطائرة بدون طيار متصلة أم لا، بكين
تلتزم الصمت  تعرف وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية
الطائرة بدون طيار باسم
tb001 الملقبة بالعقرب ثنائي الذيل
القادرة على القيام بمهام طويلة المدى على ارتفاعات عالية
وتسافر لمسافة تصل إلى 6000
كيلومتر أكثر من 3700 ميل، وهو ما
يشبه الطيران من لندن إلى نيويورك.
الميزة الكبيرة هي أنهم حصلوا على
تأمين طويل جدًا، حيث يمكنهم البقاء في
الهواء لمدة 35 إلى 40 ساعة أو حتى المزيد من
الخبراء العسكريين الذين أخبروا شبكة CNN أن الطائرة بدون طيار يمكنها
حمل حمولة أسلحة كبيرة،
والغرض الأساسي منها هو المراقبة المستمرة،
لكن الخبراء يقولون إن مهمة هذه الطائرة بدون طيار
لم تكن سرية، بل تم تنفيذها ببساطة
لأغراض العرض التوضيحي.  لمحاولة إعطاء
الانطباع بأن تايوان محاصرة،
قد يكون للصين ميزة في الجو، لكن
تايوان تكشف النقاب عن
طائراتها القتالية والمراقبة بدون طيار. وقد مُنحت شبكة CNN
الشهر الماضي وصولاً نادرًا إلى مطور أسلحة تايواني،
بما في ذلك خمسة نماذج تم الكشف عنها
للجمهور للمرة الأولى.  في الوقت الذي كان فيه الدفاع عن الطائرات بدون طيار
أولوية قصوى
للجيش التايواني، في العام الماضي، حلقت سلسلة من
الطائرات المدنية بدون طيار مجهولة الهوية من الصين
فوق مواقع عسكرية حساسة.
ما رأيك عندما شاهدت
فيديو الطائرات بدون طيار وهي تحلق فوق يا
جنودنا أسقطوا طائرة بدون طيار فوق تلك
الجزيرة  أخبرني أحد جيراني أن قوات
الدفاع التايوانية قالت لـCNN إنهم لن يتعرضوا
للترهيب، وأصروا على أنهم مستعدون
للرد على أي تهديد جوي من الصين في
أي وقت، ريبلي سي إن إن تايبيه